In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 3rd, on which we commemorate the Holy Hyromarter
Dionysius, Bishop of Alexandria and of his disciples Faustos, Gaios, Ocebius and Karimon,
the Deacons.
It Dionysius lived in the reigns of the emperors Valerian and Galianos in the years 253 through 268.
He was a disciple of origin and became a priest in Alexandria.
In the year 231, he succeeded Heraclas as director of the famous Catechetical school there.
After he became Bishop of the city in the year 247, his wisdom and demotoration were of great
help in overcoming the problems that disturbed the universal church at the time.
He fought idolatry and taught the faith in the Holy Trinity with exactness.
He resisted millenarian tendencies that twisted the sense of Holy Scripture and intervened
at Rome against novation, who had spread schism in many churches.
He mediated in the dispute between Saint Cyprian and the Pope about the baptism of Heretics,
and was concerned throughout his episcopacy to strengthen the church in the bond of charity.
At the time of Decius, in the years 249 through 251, he fled into the Libyan desert to escape
persecution.
In the reign of Valerian in the years 257 through 258, Emilianos became governor of Alexandria.
He summoned before his tribunal Dionysius, his disciples, and the faithful who had joined
them from Rome, with the demand that they deny Christ.
As they refused to sacrifice to the vain gods, the governor exiled them to a desert village,
called Kefro, forbidding all converse and connection between themselves or with other Christians.
But the faithful were drawn to Kefro in great numbers, seeking consolation in the presence
and words of the renowned Holy Bishop.
And besides, many pagans in the locality were converted, so that the saints exile took
on the character of a missionary labor.
When Emilianos got to hear of this, he had them removed to a place deeper in the wilderness,
the haunt of the brigands and murderers, where they endured many tribulations.
They were stoned and then confined to an arid and unhealthy place for more than 12 years.
The saints Dionysius, Gaia's and Faustos, all died there and departed to the mansions
of the blessed, having fought the good fight and kept the faith even to the end.
The deacon Ocevius and the priest Maximus escaped from this exile and spent the rest of their
lives visiting the confessors of the faith and honoring the relics of the Holy Martyrs.
Ocebius became Bishop of Laudicea and Maximus succeeded St. Dionysius on the throne of Alexandria.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.